Oklahoma set out to take on a
pharmaceutical giant and after seven
weeks of evidence judge Thad Bachmann's
ruling was blunt he found that Johnson &
Johnson is culpable in fueling an opioid
crisis it's claimed more than 6,000
lives in this state the opioid crisis
has ravaged the state of Oklahoma
it must be emitted abated immediately
for this reason I am entering an
abatement plan that consists of costs
totaling 572 million one hundred two
thousand and twenty eight dollars to
immediate lead remediate the nuisance
the case is being seen as a landmark
ruling in dealing with a health crisis
it's claimed tens of thousands of lives
across the u.s. the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention say that in 2017
alone close to 50 thousand people died
from opioid overdoses lawyer Reggie
Whitten was part of Oklahoma's legal
team and lost his firstborn son to
addiction lawyers for Johnson & Johnson
say they'll appeal the decision calling
it legally flawed the state's lawyers
were asking for 17 billion dollars from
the company but only got a fraction of
that the amount of money that Johnson &
Johnson has been ordered to pay may not
be what the state of Oklahoma wanted but
the message it sends is clear the judge
in this case was unequivocal in blaming
big pharmaceutical companies in their
role in an opioid crisis that's blighted
the lives of so many and with thousands
of other cases across the country this
may set an important precedent two of
the pharmaceutical companies Purdue and
Teva settle before this trial got
underway with Monday's ruling Oklahoma
now has close to a billion dollars for
treatment and this is being seen as a
huge victory by those that work on the
front lines fighting the epidemic we're
very very happy this is a good day for
the state of Oklahoma we took on a giant
major pharmaceutical company
a judge in Norman Oklahoma said you
killed people it's time to pay the case
was being closely watched across the
u.s. in Ohio alone there are 2000
pending cases but after Monday's ruling
pharmaceutical companies may now be
forced to pay out billions and the
Gallacher al-jazeera
Norman Oklahoma